I want to talk about positive [ __ ] yeah
and the next positive thing I want to
[ __ ] bring up with something that we
saw last night oh yeah we saw the movie
the arriving arrival who you already
[ __ ] it up was it go [ __ ] survival
the arrival arrival the right Jerry what
I say what I say the arriving no I
didn't he said the arriving Oh whatever
they arrived that's true they did that
they were arriving or they did alright
coming they're coming they're coming
Amy Adams Jeremy Jeremy let me see
something right now I did not want to go
for what reason I don't know I just
didn't want to go and because mainly
because my brother said it was a
masterpiece last week my brother was on
tour and he text me you got to watch the
arrival it's a masterpiece and the
things that he called masterpieces are
weird like like only the ignition to
Mars it was a move commissioned he
called it a masterpiece a piece of [ __ ]
but we saw it and you know half we're
doing the movie I'm like pretty good
it's well paced what I loved it sound
designed also they made some very strong
choices about the aliens depicting the
aliens and they made them like very
something that we've never seen before
in movies and I thought I was really
didn't have an opinion about Amy Adams
but by watching her in this movie I'm
like wow this [ __ ] can [ __ ] act her
ass off Oscar oh yeah for sure for sure
oh yeah and then about 70 percent 80
percent into the movie I just found
myself
weeping yeah oh it's the last I'd say
the last 20 minutes of the movie all you
heard and he's not just teary-eyed
I mean his body is like convoy yeah it
really got to me it made me so it made
me cry but I knew in in the port that I
was crying out wasn't even sad
it wasn't yeah I like I started crying
when I it wasn't and then when it got
sad admit it you only started crying
when I leaned over and whispered in your
ear and made you real
the twist of the movie no you wouldn't
even understand it up.i no no no no
here's what happened
I was crying before that what about the
Chinese do ya
okay I don't know why yeah but that
Chinese dude made me cry that scene made
me cry and then and then when you told
me what it was right then I had to think
about it yeah so I didn't quite right
away I didn't really understand what you
were saying you were just saying if you
haven't seen the movie that's what I'm
being very vague right now but there's a
point in the movie where there's a
little bit of a kind of a switch it's a
big realization right realization big
switch it's a big switch so when she
told me I go and I thought about it and
then when it clicked I just started
crying like bad and then you're your
sister cried oh we were all crying I
think but no nuts up Renza didn't cry I
mean as a cop doesn't matter and because
he didn't cry I like the guy effect I
will say I love him yeah but there's a
little bit of a thing now what's a
little thing as a man didn't cry he
thought he loved the movie no but still
there's a little bit of a thing like
something's off if I'm crying you got
and also your mom didn't cry yeah I
thought that it was so brilliant this
movie and if you're going into it
looking for a huge action movie you're
gonna be like it's not you're gonna be
disappointed but there's so much more to
it it reminds me of 2001 space obviously
the Kubrick film because of the fact
that it's there's just symbolism you
know like that you know that the
spaceship kind of looks like the
monolith in 2001 right and there is you
know in 2001 there is a sense of time
which is a time is a very big thing in
this movie and it was just well made and
it was and also Eric Griffin today said
yeah he loved it because human eye
agree about everything yeah he didn't
like the winch he didn't like the witch
but he said you know that he gave props
to it so it was still really I haven't
seen a movie like that in many many
years yeah I really enjoyed it it was
well done and Congrats yeah do anyone
involved in that mm-hmm and a [ __ ]
rodent really yeah yeah [ __ ] wrote it
yeah a Chinese guy I'm in Beijing so
he's looking to yourself I'm very
[Music]